Hello, the internet, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
And we've built this little
Lego tower, haven't we?
Slow-mopolis thing, yeah.
I'm always fascinated by how
when you film something in slow motion,
it kind of adds scale to it.
It makes everything seem a bit weightier.
Is that what they do on
Thunderbirds and stuff like that?
Yeah and like Independence Day,
it had a lot of model shots.
That's cool.
So, what are we doing with this
lovely little town we've built?
We've got a town, it
took us ages to build.
It was about a three hour build.
You wouldn't think it, but it did.
Got a plane.
Gonna crash it through
the back of Slow-mopolis
and hopefully, get some cool shots.
There's a plane right now.
Yeah.
See you later, go on.
Hopefully, we get some quite cool shots
of bits exploding everywhere,
people going flying,
buildings collapsing that sort will do.
Yeah, the pilot is unaware
he's about to have an
engine failure at six feet.
Six feet?
Six feet.
That's deadly that.
Deadly, lethal.
This guy's got no idea either,
he's just having a brew.
Yeah.
Just chillin'.
All right, let's see how we get on.
Cool.
Wanna explain what happened
last time we did this?
Well basically the plane,
there's no where good to
hold it under the wings
which would be the logical sort of,
balanced place to hold it,
so you have to hold it back
here which is unbalanced,
which means that when I threw it,
it just took a nose dive
and immediately crashed into the table.
I don't get a practice shot either.
There's no practice
and messing it up will cost us--
Hours.
Several hours of work.
God dammit.
It's really hard to throw that.
Aw, where's the plane?
Ah!
Well here's the wings.
That's gonna be a nightmare
to rebuild that plane.
What happened?
First of all, first of all,
you broke the plane in your hand
and then you threw it
I didn't--
vertically downwards onto the table.
It's completely, the center
of gravity of the plane,
it's not made for throwing.
This is it coming in.
Oh no.
You put it at such a steep angle
that you broke the back off.
I didn't break it!
And threw it downwards.
The control tower didn't even get touched.
I mean that looks really cool.
It looks cool but it doesn't
look like a plane crash.
Aw man, it just looks
like someone smashed Lego.
There's the cockpit.
That's completely gone to pieces.
This guy driving the
forklift's like "Bloody Hell!"
Still avoided some
absolute catastrophe here.
Oh man.
Looks cool.
Fuselage coming towards
the camera looks wicked.
Stuffs gone everywhere.
My favorite part is this for your face.
Oh no!
Oh, ballsed it.
I know I've messed this up.
Oh, God's sake.
Rolling.
ready?
Yeah.
Whoa!
How did that go?
Not bad, not bad.
The engine on fire burnt my arm.
Did it?
Yeah.
Oh dear.
Your face.
It's concentration look.
That looks wicked with the
engine flaming there as well.
It's cool.
Oh, you've let go.
Oh, it's gone straight for the tower.
Man.
Wiped out those buildings.
It went down sideways.
Jesus.
Bloody hell.
The plane's disintegrated.
Now the back of it's gone,
there's an engine flying towards us.
There's the fuselage.
Man, there's just Lego everywhere.
It's cool.
Your face.
So it looked like the plane
had an extreme amount of velocity
to the point where it disintegrated
and went straight through.
But then--
What we've done,
we've reconstructed it
in a very likely plane crash scenario.
This is quite realistic I think.
But, something happened when
the plane crashed didn't it?
Yeah, there was this sort
of, jet fuel went everywhere.
You know, sort of just all over the gaff.
So I've noticed this forklift guy
looks a bit like Walter White.
Hang on.
He really does, he looks exactly like him!
That's amazing!
Well that was absolute destruction.
Yeah, they didn't know
what hit them did they?
They never saw it coming.
I feel sorry for them if anything.
The whole of Slowmo-vile
is, or Slow-mopolis.
Has been--
Packed back up into it's box.
Aw, look at this guy,
he's totally charred.
His cup's melted.
His wine glass has melted.
Well, this is a stupid
video, very silly one,
hopefully you enjoyed it a little bit.
I kinda wanna do something similar
on that small a scale but larger,
if you know what I mean.
Smaller but larger.
Yeah, yeah.
Coming soon.
Does that make sense?
Be sure to subscribe to us.
You can buy a shirt, got loads of those.
Follow us on Twitter.
Thank you very much for watching.
My luggage.